Welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have our first look at Woody Harrelson
as carnage on the set of venom 2 so
we'll break it down we also have an idea
for how everything connects with Morbius
movie venom 2 and all the spider-man
stuff that they're setting up with
sinister 6 if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos so we'll talk about the venom 2
carnage scenes that they were filming
someone got some footage of them filming
on set and then Tom Hardy himself posted
some pictures of the carnage character
then quickly deleted them of course as
you would expect then I'll talk about
all the crossover stuff and how
everything connects with the Morbius
movie Michael Keaton's vulture from
spider-man homecoming and the MCU
spider-man stuff so we'll just do this
top 5 style starting with number 5
this is the picture of Cletus Kasady in
the movie that Tom Hardy just posted
revealing that they've retcon that
terrible terrible red wig away maybe
there's a scene somewhere early in the
movie where they shave it off or they
just show up at the beginning of the
film and he's already shaved it who
cares doesn't matter because they got
rid of that terrible wig but this is
still a wig that he's wearing because
Woody Harrelson is bald in real life it
just vastly improved wig that's way
shorter and suits him much more his like
they saw the drama with the sonic movie
last year and the redesign and the
negative fan response after the venom
post-credit scene with carnage and the
earlier version of his terrible wig and
said yep
right thing to do is we're just going to
change that right away doesn't matter
what his haircut looks like in the
comics if he has long hair if it looks
terrible in the movie on Woody Harrelson
we should change it and if you can't
tell because it's super dark where
they're filming this scene he's
strolling around the streets of San
Francisco at night in a red Hawaiian
shirt wearing a necklace
very subtle if he gets any other
wardrobe changes in the movie besides
wearing the carnage symbiote I'm sure
they'll try to keep his color palette in
Reds just to match the symbiote if the
symbiote itself isn't generating that
Hawaiian shirt the fact that he's
wearing civilian clothes should also
tell you that he's already escaped from
San Quentin prison so this might be
taking place towards the beginning of
the movie I'll explain the timeline in a
second but number 4 this is the footage
of the scene of them filming right after
this because he's wearing the exact same
outfit also in the San Francisco streets
just getting gunned down by a bunch of
cops trying to arrest him again you can
guess how that's going to go but if you
can't tell from the way he's moving here
he's eating all the bullets holding his
arms out making motions like the carnage
symbiote is covering him
in protecting him is the exact same type
of scene they did in the first venom
movie when the cops attacked Eddie Brock
and he tried to warn them off like you
really really don't want to do this
please don't try to attack me it's only
going to end badly for you
Mask!
Copy!
They put that scene in all the trailers
just because it was so cool but it just
seems like this carnage version is going
to be the darker version of that scene
where he just eats all the bullets then
takes out all the cops and gruesome
fashion number three what is the
timeline of the venom 2 movie and how
does Cletus Kasady get the carnage
symbiote how does he escaped from prison
we all know the carnage origin story in
the comics carnage is the offspring of
the Venom symbiote he gets it because
they were cellmates but Eddie Brock
wasn't in prison during the venom
post-credit scene so they were always
going to have to find some other way for
Cletus Kasady to get the carnage
symbiote or here's where things come
back around to the Morbius movie because
obviously whatever you think about the
MCU being connected all this stuff
because of the spider-man stuff and the
Michael Keaton stuff they're teasing the
venom movie in the Morbius movie are
directly connected Morbius is being
built as a direct spin-off of venom so
the visit of recent reports about the
Morbius movie having some shared scenes
with venom 2 that provides some
continuity and help set up him getting
the symbiote and using it to escape
prison and supposedly that also
coincides with the sinister six Michael
Keaton stuff that's setting up a
different sinister six spider-man movie
that I'll also explain in a second - but
I think the real reason why they wanted
Morbius to crossover with venom 2 and
set all this up is so they can explain
how carnage gets the symbiote and goes
on his rampage by the first act of venom
- and they don't have to spend a bunch
of time at the beginning of venom 2
explaining how that all happens they can
just start the movie and get right into
the action like we all knew what they
were saying at the end of the venom
post-credit scene they said that there
be carnage so just give us that scene
don't spend 30 minutes explaining how
they get to that scene just start off
with them going crazy number 2 so here's
the Morbius movie crossover stuff with
venom 2 and all the spider-man sinister
6 stuff there's a report stating that
during the Morbius movie he winds up
being captured by the authorities after
he gets his powers and while he's in
jail in the New York City area they
briefly sent him from New York to San
Quentin prison where carnage is
currently being held
they're also claiming that this Michael
Keaton vulture cameo seen in the Morbius
trailer isn't happening in the New York
City area even though that's where the
vulture went to jail and spider-man
homecoming they're saying that between
the events of the spider-man homecoming
post-credit scene with vulture and
scorpion Avengers Infinity Ward the
snap Avengers end game everyone getting
snapped back that since that's all
happened in the future
vulture in the sinister six characters
like the Scorpion were also transferred
to San Quentin prison in the San
Francisco area this Morbius spider-man
vulture scene is for sinister six set up
but they're using the San Quentin
location as a nexus for a bunch of
movies that they're teasing in the
future a bunch of Sony Marvel movies
like in that Morbius trailer scene with
the vulture it's implied that he's in
the middle of breaking out to set up
spider-man's sinister six movie with
vulture scorpion and also they're
setting up carnage getting the symbiote
and breaking out of prison while these
guys in the Morbius character are busy
breaking out of that prison you can make
as many theories as you want about how
much venom will cross over with
potentials so NIMH spider-man sinister
six movies I don't know anything about
that right now
right now I'm still thinking of venom as
a different franchise from spider-man
and sister 6 stuff venom was never
really in the classic sinister six
roster but I don't think that would stop
Sony from trying to include venom in any
potential sinister six spider-man
team-up movie but number one
obviously the last big thing what about
the spider-man seen in the Morbius
trailer if they're already teasing
spider-man crossover in Morbius which is
coming out in July this year
what kind of spider-man venom carnage
crossover will they tease in venom two
well the same report about the sinister
six
carnage venom stuff happening in the
Morbius movie also went on to say that
this scene of Morbius walking past the
spider-man picture is the only actual
spider-man we get during the movie like
Tom Holland himself doesn't have a real
cameo seen during the Morbius movie it
just him walking past this letting you
know that spider-man exists within this
world but it does clarify what's going
on with the Tobey Maguire spider-man
suit this is it in the final version of
the movie they're going to digitally
replace this Tobey suit with the Tom
Hollands spider-man far from home suit
so it'll make way more sense there were
a lot of big spider verse theories like
maybe they're setting up spider-man into
the spider verse if this version of
spider-man is going to be Tobey Maguire
in this Morbius venom universe even
though that does sound like a really
cool idea it just sounds like what Sony
is actually doing it's just misleading
us and they're going to change it in the
final version of the movie it'll be way
simpler to explain which version of
spider-man this is they do it all the
time and Marvel MCU trailers they did it
during Avengers in
he wore Avengers endgames thor ragnarok
this is just the latest example of a big
Hollywood studio misleading you with
footage in a trailer so if there was any
confusion just don't expect Tom Holland
himself to be walking around inside the
morbius movie but venom to spider-man
scenes will probably wind up being much
bigger if they're just going to sort of
continue that idea of setting up the
idea of spider-man within this universe
spider-man has a much deeper connection
to the venom character in the comics so
it would be weird for him to have a huge
moment in the Morbius movie but then not
in venom too so of course while
expecting something big in venom 2 maybe
a big venom 2 post-credit scene with the
actual Tom hall and spider-man on screen
there were reports that Sony was
negotiating with Tom Hollands people for
an actual venom 2 cameo scene sort of in
the vein of Michael Keaton's vulture
cameo seen during the Morbius movie
something on that level with Tom Holland
in venom 2 bonus - there's also the
idea that they're using Jay jonah
jameson as a point of crossover to
connect all the MCU and all the Sony
verse spider-verse venom verse stuff
however you want to think about it so if
you remember the spider-man bar from
home post credits scene with Jay jonah
Jameson doing his Daily Bugle dotnet
rant on spider-man supposedly there's
going to be something like that during
the Morbius movie at some point when
he's in and around the New York City
area in the present day of the film and
I think if that winds up being truth and
that will also confirm that he's
probably going to show up doing the
exact same thing during venom 2 he has
all the Daily Bugle stuff that we saw on
the set of Morbius movie was from the
Tobey Maguire era where the Daily Bugle
had this logo it was a newspaper it
wasn't the Daily Bugle dotnet but if
this version of spider-man is going to
be digitally replaced with the Tom
Holland Spiderman far from home suit
they might wind up doing the same thing
with the Easter eggs for the Daily Bugle
when they're calling out spider-man
spider-man missing where is he but we'll
see everybody let me know in the
comments what do you want them to do
with Tom Holland spider-man inside venom
- are you hoping for a post-credits
scene or just some brief cameo scene or
maybe just some stock footage of him
showing up on a Jay jonah Jameson
broadcast with him yelling about how
spider-man is a villain needs to be
captured remember the Morbius trailer
apparently spider-man cannot be found
nobody knows where he is no joke The
Daily Bugle dot net is a real web site the
Sony created to promote
the spider-man movies but it also sounds
like they're going to use it to promote all
the spider-verse stuff the venom verse
and the Morbius stuff too I will do more
venom in Morbius spider-man videos soon
the venom 2 trailer should be released
sometime in March so of course I'll do a
video for that whenever it comes next
year Sony is actually releasing two
spider-man movies spider-man 3 and then
a mystery spider-man movie that they
have not revealed yet click here for my
video all about that and what movie I
think that's going to wind up being and
click here for my new Avengers infinity
saga deleted scene thank you so much for
watching everyone stay awesome.
This is the way!